In this segment, we discuss the
so-called "random incidence"
paradox for the Poisson process.
It's a paradox
because it involves
a somewhat counterintuitive
phenomenon.
However, we will understand
exactly what's going on,
and in the end, it will
cease to be a paradox
and we will have an
intuitive understanding
of what exactly is happening.
So consider a Poisson process
that has been running forever,
or think of it as a
Poisson process that
started a very long
time back in the past.
To make things concrete,
suppose that the arrival rate
is 4 arrivals per hour so that
the expected interarrival time
is one fourth, in
hours, or that would
be the same as 15 minutes.
For example, suppose that
the bus company in your town
claims that buses
arrive to your stop
according to a Poisson process
with this particular rate.
But you don't really believe
that your bus company is
telling the truth and you
decide to investigate.
So what you do is the following.
You show up at some
time at your bus stop
and wait until the
next arrival comes
and also ask someone
who lives near the bus
stop, what time was
the last arrival?
And they tell you
the last arrival
happened at that time instant.
And you measure
this amount of time,
which is the interarrival
time, record what it is,
repeat this experiment on many
days, and calculate an average.
What you're likely
to see turns out
to be something
around 30 minutes.
At this point, you could
go to the bus company
and challenge them.
You claim an arrival rate of
4 arrivals per hour, which
would translate into
interarrivals of 15 minutes,
but every day I go and
check the interarrival time
and I find that they
are close to 30 minutes.
What's the explanation?
What's going on?
Is it that the belief or
the claim of the bus company
is incorrect, or is there
something more complicated?
So let us try to
understand what's
going on by being very
precise and careful.
You show up at the bus
station at some time--
let's call that time t star.
You ask someone who has
been at the station,
when was the last arrival
time, and they tell you,
and it is some number U.
You wait until the next bus,
and the next bus arrives
at some future time capital
V. You are interested
in the interarrival time
that you're observing,
which is the difference
between these two random
variables V minus U.
Now this difference-- let
us split it into two pieces.
There's one piece
from t star until V,
which is V minus t star.
And there's another piece,
which is the first interval,
and this is t star minus U. Now
t star, the time at which you
arrive, is just a constant.
Suppose that you arrive at the
bus station at exactly 12 noon.
There's nothing random about it.
However, V and U are
random variables.
What kind of random
variable is this?
You show up at 12 noon and you
wait until the first arrival.
Because a Poisson process
starts fresh at any given time--
so after 12 noon it
starts fresh-- this
is the time until the first
arrival in a Poisson process
with rate lambda, so
this is a random variable
which is exponential
with parameter lambda.
Now let us understand what
this random variable is.
One way of thinking
about it is to think
of the Poisson process
running backwards in time,
so you live time backwards.
You show up at 12 noon, and
then time runs backwards,
and you wait until you see
the first arrival coming
in this backwards universe.
So we're dealing
here with the time
until an arrival in
a Poisson process
that runs backwards in time.
What kind of process is a
backwards Poisson process?
If you take a Poisson
process in reverse time,
the independence
assumption is not affected.
Disjoint time intervals
are independent.
Even if you reverse time,
disjoints time intervals
still remain independent.
Any given time interval
of small length delta
will have certain
probabilities of an arrival
or of two arrivals, and
these will be the same
whether time goes forward
or time goes backward.
So the conclusion
from this discussion
is that the backwards
running Poisson process
is also a Poisson
process, and so this time
until the first arrival
in the backwards process
is just like the time until
the first arrival in a Poisson
process.
So this also is an
exponential random variable
with parameter lambda.
Even more than that,
these two random variables
are independent of each other.
Why are they independent?
The length of this
time interval has
to do with the history
of the Poisson process
after time t star.
The length of this
time interval has
to do with the history
of the Poisson process
before time t star, but in
the Poisson process because
of the independence property,
the past and the future
are independent, and
therefore, this random variable
is independent from
that random variable.
In any case, the expected value
of the interarrival interval
that you see, the expected
value of this random variable,
is going to be the expected
value of one exponential, which
is 1 over lambda,
plus the expected
value of another exponential,
which is 1 over lambda,
and we get a result
of 2 over lambda.
And that's why when you actually
carried out the experiment,
you saw interarrival
intervals that
had a length of 30 minutes
as opposed to the 15 minutes
that you were expecting
in the first place.
Now how can this be?
Since the interarrival
times in a Poisson process
have expected value
1 over lambda,
how can it be that
the expected length
of the interarrival
times that you see
have an expected value
of 2 over lambda?
Well, the resolution of this
paradox has to do [with]
what exactly we mean when we use
the words an interarrival time.
There's one interpretation which
is the first interarrival time,
the second one, the
hundredth interarrival time--
each one of these
actually has an expected
value of 1 over lambda.
But this is a different
kind of interarrival time.
It's not the first
or the second or
some specific k-th
interarrival time.
It's the interarrival time
that you selected to watch.
When you show up at a
certain time, like 12 noon,
you're more likely to fall
inside a large interarrival
interval rather than a
smaller interarrival interval.
So just the fact that
you're showing up
at a certain time
that's uncoordinated
with the rest of
the process makes
you more likely to be
biased towards longer
rather than shorter intervals.
And this bias is what
causes this factor of 2.
So it's an issue really
about how you sample
or how you choose
the interarrival time
that you're going to watch,
and this particular sampling
method has a bias
towards longer intervals.
As we will see, this
is not something
that's specific to
the Poisson process.
In general, in many
occasions there
are different ways of
sampling which give you
different answers, and we will
go through a number of examples
that will give you some
intuition about the source
of the discrepancy
between these two answers.